what's poppin rockstars my name is mt
and the newest trailer for james guns
the suicide squad has just hit the
internet and it is somehow
even more crazier than we expected it to
be like i'm trying to think of another
movie that ends with a giant starfish
kaiju fighting a clown lady and a bird
watching shark but gosh i can't seem to
do it but anyways this senile old brown
man has rambled long enough
let's find us some delicious nerdy
tidbits in this trailer my nerd babies
and right off the bat we get
bloodsport's real name robert dubois
said by the ruthless task force x master
general
amanda shoot my employees to build
morale waller
inside of the bell rev correctional
center who goes on to reveal that the
reason why dubois is even in there in
the first place is because he made
the man of steel kneel with a kryptonite
bullet
answering the age-old question do you
play it yes
yes he does which aligns with robert
dubois character in the comics as the
evil bald known as lex luthor
gives robert the ability to summon a
kryptonite gun
to shoot and kill superman which he does
well you know the first part anyway
because clark is a tough space cookie to
crack it's hard to kill that man now
this could be significant because if you
remember at the end of the original
justice league
the less good version eisenberg luther
says that he's starting a league of our
own with
some of the villainous faces of the dceu
and bloodsport
could very well have been part of
luthor's new team
and hell part of me even believes that
bloodsport could actually have some
decent reasons
behind him shooting superman in the
first place because i don't know if you
remember this but the day superman and
zod decided to world star all over
metropolis
a lot of people died they're probably a
lot of earthlings that have no love for
superman despite everything he's done so
luther and dubois would have a common
enemy there but moving on when waller
makes the
immense mistake of having pens around
while threatening the families of known
killers
we see that while this cold-blooded
woman doesn't even flinch
there is a degree of fear within her
voice when she yells at her men to put
their guns down
probably because she realizes if they
don't there is a very good chance
bloodsport would kill her immediately
and then
just deal with whatever consequences
that happened after that
because in the comics bloodsport does
suffer from a pretty significant
form of mental illness so this could
very well be a factor that waller is
aware of
so she's just like chill please just put
the guns down because this man is in
murder mode and he's gonna do it
he's crazy and as the trailer continues
we see the familiar shot
of the suicide squad assembling for
their mission at what is revealed later
on in the trailer as
the bell rev correctional center
detachment ii military airlift support
squadron
military airlift command belrev is of
course the facilities that hold dc's
most dangerous criminals like our
suicide squad and
lex luthor you know before lex luthor
found some random bald white guy to
stare at a wall so he could go out
boating with the homies
but before i continue i want to thank
monster legends for sponsoring this
video monster legends is a free-to-play
game available on both android and ios
collect monsters choose different sets
of skills and boost your strategy in
action-packed battles
start by building a world for your
monsters to live and fill it with
habitats
and breed monsters of different elements
and rarities to create cool new species
because the species we have on earth not
enough and you can fight in real time
against your friends in pvp modes and
team up with other monster masters to
chat
strategize and fight in epic team wars
and earn
exclusive monsters and monster legends
has hundreds of different monsters to
collect
level and rank up for the battles ahead
in the monster lab
and there are new events every week to
discover and play new adventures
i really dig the sense of humor in this
game like the action is fun in like a
cartoony way and the game doesn't take
itself too seriously which is great
because neither do i i
never do like this is a game where you
literally breed monsters to make
other monsters this is pretty cool like
look at this man he's wearing a fedora
now download the game through the link
in the description to get a special
award worth thirty dollars
for a limited time only until july third
you can get 10 gems
50 000 food 300 000 gold and the epic
monster
kaori and bell rev is of course the home
of argus the who run the
suicide squad we of course get a look at
the argus offices
in this trailer and others but new to
this trailer is actress jennifer holland
who appears to be playing an assistant
type character
to amanda waller and despite this being
a job she
might just share a similar moral code to
that of wallers as she is seen
smirking in this trailer after dubois
initially refuses to join and amanda
waller says
we'll see and holland also happens to be
director james gunn's partner and i got
to meet her a few years ago
and she was a very nice lady so but as
the trailer introduces members of the
suicide squad like javelin
captain boomerang blackguard mongal
savant and the child murdering
weasel jesus christ 27 kids that's a lot
of kids
we can see what is in my opinion the
best part of the trailer
a rat on rat catcher's shoulder waving
at somebody in the prison i personally
would like to think that the rat was
waving at me
as i am a prisoner of my own emotions
now i can't speak for your experience
exactly but my ass has never seen a rat
wave to me before that wasn't named
charles entertainment cheese
so this sort of gives us more of an idea
of how ratcatcher's mental connection
with rat's work i mean we do see her
utilize her rat wand that she uses to
control
an apartment complex with the rats later
on in this trailer
wow that's a lot of rats but it does
appear that she can communicate and
control rats
without this one so that's really
interesting to me or maybe she's just
really good friends with rats
and in the next frame we see classic dc
villain that everyone knows and loves
abner krill the depressed polka dot man
who is finally seen smiling and having a
good time later on in this trailer when
he's shooting his dots
feeling like a real superhero and
assuming that that moment of him being
happy happens more towards the end of
the film when they are battling starro
it wouldn't necessarily surprise me to
find out that the reason why abdur
became imprisoned in bellrev in the
first place was because he tried to be a
superhero but somehow polka dot goofed
himself into becoming a criminal because
judging by the way abner shoots these
super hot dots at these soldiers in this
trailer i can totally see polkadot man
accidentally killing a couple of
innocent people while trying to be a
hero he doesn't seem like the
type to have really refined hero skills
because most of these hot ass dots can
melt right through these cubicles with
ease
so my advice don't get polka dot man
started because if your ass gets spotted
your ass gonna get dotted you got it
and that's on abner motherfu and
speaking of these cubicles they appear
to be part of the old
naughty prison of yotenheim located in
the country of cordo maltese the very
location
waller sends the squad to erase all
traces of something she calls
project starfish which is i would hope
in reference to the big ass starfish
up in all these trailers the super
villain known as
starrow but these cubicles appear to be
a floor under this aquarium tank that
the adorable
king shark watches his cousins in before
it completely shatters and leaks through
this massive hole into the office space
below which is probably why
harley quinn is underwater here and
because ratcatcher is obviously the most
powerful dc character of all time
these rats are probably on their way to
save harley from drowning but hey
speaking of project starfish when waller
drops the name we see peter capaldi's
thinker with the dictator of quarter
maltese
sylvia luna looking into a tank with
tentacles creepily floating about
that right there is starro i know it
doesn't look like staro but
later on the trailer while starro is
like slamming king shark into a freaking
building we see sharky being held by
these gross tentacles that pop
out of one of staro's legs like these
legs literally contain these weird
little ropey thingies that he presumably
uses
to hold smaller since that giant
starfish doesn't have arms which makes
sense but good god is it unsettling
also as unsettling as the mini owes that
come out of starro as well
disgusting who are most likely the
reason why king shark has all those bite
marks all over his body
in these trailers also what's really
interesting about this moment between
finker and luna is that the nodes on
thinker's head are actually
lit this time whereas in previous
trailers they weren't
ever lit and i think some of them were
actually broken i'm willing to bet that
this is a flashback to events that
happened shortly before the events of
this film
with luna using thinker to possibly
communicate or just understand the
science behind starro before
thinker is stolen by amanda waller now
since it has been revealed that the
yotenheim prison in this movie has been
used in the past
to experiment on prisoners to create
metahumans to fight in world war ii
i think it's quite likely that thinker
could have been one of those very same
meta-humans that was experimented on or
even a former nazi scientist that used
to work there that experimented
on himself and he could very well have
some type of mental link between himself
and starro if this is the case
this would explain why finker is needed
on this mission because a
he would know the layout of jotunheim
extremely well and b
he could be the key to stopping starro
and this could also explain ratcatcher's
role in the squad as she also has a
connection with animals
so having both thinker and rat catcher
in this jotenheim elevator
together with flag makes perfect sense
to me but now that we're thinking about
thinker i would guess that this shot of
a sweaty abner holding thinker
probably happens after thinker tries to
make a run for it during the squad's
night out on the town
thus risking the brains of everyone on
the team which is why
abner is sweating because he's like oh
if i don't catch this man i'm going to
die because if anyone doesn't have a
bomb in their head it's probably the
dude with a bunch of hardware already
attached to his brain which probably
leads to the team threatening him
on the roof we fail a mission you die we
find out any information you give us is
false
you die if we find out you have
personalized license plates
you duck but anyways while the team
discusses whether or not weasel is an
afghan hound
harley quinn says oh my god a werewolf
seemingly and hopefully
pointing to the existence of werewolves
in the dc eu
you know like gotham's kyle abbott or
even laron
of krypton because frankly i want to see
that let's make that happen warner
brothers let's get some werewolves in
this
this glance between harley and rick flag
shows that these two
genuinely care about each other as
friends especially when you think back
to their interaction during rick's
unnecessary rescue attempt from an
earlier trailer what are you guys doing
here to save you you were gonna save me
this is a really good plan too
well i can go back inside and you can
still do it so expect these two to have
like a war buddies vibe throughout this
film and of course if you decide to
battle a giant kaiju without a megazord
your ass is probably gonna make the news
and the lower third on the suicide
squad's news story in this trailer says
metahuman monster battle spurs political
unrest which is significant considering
that actress alice braga is playing
solsoria a rebel dedicated to toppling
sylvia luna's tyrannical regime
so it would seem that the actions of the
squad during their final fight with
starr
might give sorya and her rebels the
tactical advantage they need to take
sylvia luna and his soldiers out
of the equation but anyways as harley
quinn is running to avoid being squashed
by
a building we see starro's big ass eye
to the left of the screen here
seemingly suggesting that this building
is not falling accidentally but because
starro is
purposely pushing this building onto
harley quinn and if this is the case
then starro possesses a
higher intellect than your average giant
sea monster because why focus your giant
eye on harley when you presumably have
an army and the rest of the suicide
squad trying to bring you down because
most kaiju would probably just be like
all right i'm gonna swipe everybody i'm
not thinking about one person
that i'll get her later harley
probably holds a key to stopping starro
at this moment
and starro knows it so he's probably
like i'ma just go ahead and
drop this apartment complex full of rats
on this small clown lady and finally
when
king shark hilariously informs the team
of a local avian creature crucial to the
mission rick flag calls him
nanawe which is actually king shark's
name in the comics the name nanaway of
course comes from a hawaiian legend that
tells of a humanoid shark so dc decided
to use that
as the basis for king shark's name so
while ratatouille is rick flagg's code
name for ratcatcher
i think that nanawe could literally just
be the name that everyone calls king
shark in this movie because why the hell
would king shark need a codename he's a
shark but anyways that is it for my
breakdown of this trailer but what did
you guys think and what are you guys
most excited about let us know in the
comment section
below my nerd babies anyways thank you
guys so much for watching this video and
please don't forget to download
monster legends and start playing today
using the link in the description
do it it's fun you can follow me at
mastertainment on twitter and instagram
wherever i am which you can see me post
some weird stuff but most importantly
please follow new rockstars on twitter
wherever else but most importantly
on youtube and make sure that you hit
that notification bell so you can get
notifications whenever we upload a video
and also be sure to hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com
to look at our latest obsession shirt
that is only here
for a limited time so you guys better
get on that because it ain't gonna be
around forever but yes
thanks again for watching and take it
easy guys
[Music]
you